an alleged drunk driver caught on camera
just moments before and during a crash
just another example of dangers on
southern nevada roads the 8 news now
i-team's vanessa murphy has the story
that you're seeing here first now we
want to warn you about sensitive audio
and video in this report
a pickup truck appears to follow a
motorcycle at high speed and then
crashes
the driver of the pickup truck appears
to hang out of his window the driver of
the white suv he crashed into gets out
and looks for help and scarlett thompson
who caught this all on her dash cam
tells siri to call 911
one watch the address of your emergency
um hi we're on green valley parkway i'm
going north my hands are violently
shaking so i was afraid that it would
take longer
for me to type in 9-1-1 than to
tell siri
this was saturday before 8 p-m on green
valley parkway near windmill three
people were treated for minor injuries
according to a spokeswoman for the city
of henderson police say the driver of
the pickup truck is 26 year old chase
skenendor and he was taken into custody
for driving under the influence and five
other charges according to this arrest
report obtained by the eight news now
i-team skenendor had an open can of
course in his truck he could barely keep
his eyes open had difficulty standing
and refused to take a field sobriety
test he claimed the motorcycle
sideswiped him and police say he spat in
an officer's face court records show
skenendor also had a reckless driving
conviction from 2020. one condition was
to attend dui school i want to say it
kind of makes sense
i feel like somebody who behaves that
way
is most likely to have a history i don't
understand how people think it's okay to
drink and drive thompson says she has a
dash cam video for reasons just like
what happened saturday as long as the
car battery is on it turns on i've only
been driving for about two years but
i've i feel like i've avoided so many
close calls that never resulted in
anything but could have
she says since the crash she hasn't
driven at night and she keeps
remembering seeing the pickup truck in
her rear view barreling toward her the
video plays in my head whether
whether i'm watching it or not
i don't really know how to describe it
it was like everything went into slow
motion
it's like
i thought a million different things all
at once and nothing at all vanessa
murphy live local now